hello everyone I am mang and welcome to
the simply learn YouTube channel in this
particular video I won't be providing
any specific tutorials but rather than
delving into some crucial and trending
topics we will be discussing project QA
and its significance along with the
concept like artificial general
intelligence AGI and the recent events
like the open air drama so now let's
rewind a bit and discuss the open ey
drama so last month open ey underwent
substantial changes including the firing
and the subsequent Return of the CEO Sam
Alman and a complete overhaul of the
board so while official statement
mentioned a communication gap
speculation arose about a possibilities
linked to the project
qar so now I will walk you through some
interviewing aspect of this
project so project qar revolves around
creating an AI model with the knowledge
of AGI artificial Jour intelligence
allowing it to solve complex Le Lex
mathematical equation and handle diverse
use case more efficiently than humans so
the model capabilities were described as
groundbreaking as it exemplified
Advanced reasoning skills similar to
those exhibited by the humans so the
concern arises from the potential risk
to the humanity as AI system could
surpass human intelligence consider this
simple scenario imagine I'm playing a
game of chess against an AI board so now
the AI model equipped with artificial
general intelligence AGI can anticipate
the next 30 40 or maybe 50 moves
exploring all the potential 15 to 50
possibilities that might occur so
ultimately achieve to win against me
while this capability already exist the
Intriguing aspect is that with AGI in
real time the AGI becomes remarkably
intelligent so it can devise its own
strategies surpassing our human ability
to generate new ideas on the flight so
AGI proves to be more adapt than us in
this aspect this feasibility is where
project qar come into play and if you
also want to learn Technologies like
AIML then try giving simply learns
postgraduate program in Ai and ml from P
University in collaboration with IBM so
this course Theses in demand skills such
as machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering CH gbt
and many more our curriculum equips you
with the skills and knowledge to excel
in your career with a structured
learning approach and Industry relevant
projects you will be able to tackle
complex challenges and stay at the
Forefront of this field after completing
this course simply learn Learners have
made successful career transition
boosted career growth and C salary hikes
so don't forget to check out course link
from the description box below and the
pin comment so now let's discuss concern
for humans about project qar so there
are multiple factors contributing to the
perceived threat of project qar so
number one enhanced logical reasoning
and Abstract concept understanding so
the project qar remarkably Proficiency
in logical reasoning and comprehension
of abstract concept signifies a
substantial advancement in AI
capabilities however this breakthrough
introduces the potential for
unpredictable behaviors or the decision
that may prove challenging for human to
foresee so second one is Fusion of deep
learning and programmed rules the
inclusion of Q learning and AAR search
technique in qar nomenclature suggest a
blending of established AI methods this
technology of deep learning with human
program rules amplifies the model
adaptability and potential making its
integrate to manage or predict so the
third one is progress towards artificial
general intelligence AGI project qar
signifies a noteworthy step towards
realizing AGI a concept that has sparked
extensive debate in the AI Community AGI
if achieved could surpass human
capabilities in various domains posing
challenges related to control safety and
ethical consideration fourth one is
innovation in idea generation Q Stars
capacity to generate novel ideas and
proactively addresses issue before they
arise in the noteworthy however this
capability raises the possibility of AI
making decision or taking action Beyond
human comprehension or control the fifth
one is concern about unintended
consequences and misuse the advanced
capabilities of qar raise apprehensions
regarding potential misu or unforeseen
consequences in the wrong hands an AI of
this magnitude could pose a significant
threat to the humanity even if initially
deployed with intentions so the
narrative touches upon the communication
gap between open AI CEO Sam Alman and
the board l leading to his designation
so report suggest that researcher
expressed concern about project qar
stating it could be harmful to humanity
however the exact details remain
speculative until a major AGI system is
developed so in summary project Q
represent an endava to create AGI posing
potential risk to humanity the video
aims to provide insight into this
concept emphasizing the uncertainity
surrounding ai's impact on society and
the job market please share your
thoughts in comments in the video
description and we will look forward
addressing any question in future and
more detailed videos so thank you for
watching stay safe and keep learning
with simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn ner up and get certified
click
here